ja also meine These ist dass die Ampel
dafür sorgt dass wir gerade in ganz ganz
schwierigen Zeiten Deutschland bezahlbar
halten das ist Leben bezahlbar bleibt
ich denke Olaf Scholz und diese neue
Bundesregierung sind ein Glücksfall für
Deutschland wir haben in ganz
schwierigen Zeiten hohe Inflation
Entlastung für Menschen geschafft wir
haben ein Gaspreis der sich verdreifacht
hat und nach der gaspreisbremse werden
am Ende des Jahres wird eine vierköpfige
Familie beispielsweise nicht mehr zahlen
als vorher das heißt sparen sich sehr
sehr viel Geld wir haben eine
strompreisbremse wo eine vierköpfige
Familie im Monat 30 € sich sparen wird
wir haben jetzt den gordischen Knoten
beim deutschland-ticket Durchstoßen wir
können mit 49 € allen Pendlerinnen und
Händlern ein super Angebot machen
übrigens nicht nur in den Städten
sondern auch auf dem Land ich habe da
ein Beispiel mal mitgebracht wenn man
täglich pendelt von Landshut nach
München dann zahlt man heute 389 Euro
und das wird danach auf 49 Euro
zurückgehen das heißt es ist eine
unglaubliche Ersparnis und es heißt auch
diese Ampel modernisiert das Land denn
es geht nicht einfach nur Entlastungen
sondern wir setzen auch Anreize dafür
dass Menschen umsteigen dass sie
wirklich den öffentlichen Nahverkehr
stärken
und beim Thema Modernisierung
Energiewende beispielsweise jetzt
kürzlich aus dem Koalitionsausschuss ja
wir wollen das neue Heizungen zu 65% aus
Erneuerbaren gespeist werden aber es
soll sich auch jeder leisten können also
ich sag mal große Entlastungen in großen
Zeiten der Krise und gleichzeitig
Modernisierung die Ampel ist gut für
Deutschland
demokratisches Statement denn
danke
das sind ganz viele Wohltaten eins der
Probleme dabei ist dass sie die
staatsver in wahnsinnige Höhen treiben
inzwischen das hat auch schon unter der
großen Koalition angefangen das jetzt
nicht nur Schuld der Ampel aber das
trägt natürlich in wahnsinniger Weise
zur Inflation bei und das wiederum macht
es Menschen dann sehr viel schwerer also
nicht es ist schon eine tote Spirale und
sozusagen das darin ist ja der
Bundeskanzler der absolute sozusagen
großkönner und Großmeister also
sozusagen von der eigenen Arbeit gut zu
reden also jetzt nach diesem diesen sehr
sehr langen Koalitionstreffen waren wir
schon bei drei sehr also sehr sehr sehr
gute Ergebnisse haben wir immer und es
ist immer alles ganz hervorragend und
damit passt nicht so ganz zusammen also
ich will das gar nicht hinabrede stellen
was sie was sie positiv getan haben es
geht mal wieder nicht sehr mit der SPD
nach Hause auch ein Problem würde dass
sie SPD mal nachdenken müsste und das
Vertrauen in Holz in die demokratischen
Institution und gerade in die koalitions
tragenden Parteien ist katastrophal
niedrig das ist ganz dramatisch gefallen
in den ersten 15 Monaten ihre
Regierungszeit und da müsste da finde
ich würde ich mich selber doch wenn ich
daran beteiligt wäre an dieser Regierung
einfach mal fragen woran liegt das also
sind die Leute alle zu blöd zu verstehen
was wir für tolle Wohltaten machen oder
gibt es doch sozusagen eigentlich andere
Bedürfnisse eine andere
Prioritätensetzung ich habe vorhin schon
mal gesagt sie haben sehr stark und dann
ich kenne auch die Grünen ganz gut
sozusagen auch aus eigenen politischen
erleben die haben den höchsten nervaktor
in jeder politischen Konstellation das
heißt die setzen sich weil die haben
auch die Moral auf ihrer Seite haben wir
einfach Recht und man ist dann geneigt
da sehr viel nachzugeben und insofern
ist das Klima sehr stark vor der Klammer
und ich glaube also dass die Menschen in
diesem Land ganz stark wahrnehmen dass
das eine wichtige Frage ist aber das ist
andere gibt die ganz ganz schlimm brach
liegen und Sie haben recht es ist ein
schönes günstiges Ticket wenn dann
überhaupt mal ein Zug fährt und wenn er
pünktlich fährt und wenn er nicht
ausfällt eine Kollegin von mir sitzt
gerade seit acht Stunden mit ihrer
Tochter in der Notaufnahme die hat über
40 Fieber und starke Magenschmerzen und
es hat keiner Zeit sich das anzusehen
also wir haben ein riesiges Problem im
Gesundheits- und Pflegebereich wir haben
das funktionale Schulen wo also Kinder
mit Migrationshintergrund und Deutsch
ständige Kinder alle also zum großen
Anteilen rauskommen können
im Grunde Verdi braucht gar nicht mehr
groß zu streiten um den Verkehrskollaps
herbeizuführen also wir haben
fundamentale Probleme in diesem Land und
man hat das Gefühl okay die Ampel
adressiert also mit großen applom jetzt
sozusagen diese eine Frage sozusagen
deren Eintreten also der der
prognostizierten Katastrophe immer noch
nur eine Katastrophe ist und in der
Zukunft liegt aber wir haben sehr viel
Elend und sehr viele Probleme im Hier
und Jetzt die Leute haben das Gefühl ihr
Land funktioniert irgendwie nicht mehr
und also ich weiß nicht wenn ich der
Kanzler wäre und ich hätte seine
Beliebtheit und zutrauenswerte und diese
Probleme würde ich mich mal fragen ob
ich was anderes adressieren muss zu
wenig kritisch mit sich ins Gericht
vielleicht zumindest auch hinter den
Kulissen vielleicht finden die Gespräche
die Frau Gaschke sich hier wünscht
zumindest in der Koalition oder in der
parteilich statt also ich denke wir
haben ein ganzes Bündel an Problemen wir
hatten die Pandemie zu Beginn dieser
Regierungszeit sehr sehr gegenwärtig wir
haben jetzt diesen eroberungs und
Angriffskrieg vom Putin wir haben die
damit zusammenhängen der Energiekrise
wir haben die Inflation und diese
Regierung hat auf all diese Fragen
Antworten gegeben
der Inbegriff das ist ja wirklich der
der Inbegriff fehlender Selbstkritik
wenn Sie den Satz sagen die Ampel ist
gut für unser Land dann muss ich kurz
innehalten und überlege ob das real
Satire sein soll das ist so ähnlich wie
wenn wir den bundestagskanzler bei der
bei der Regierungserklärung zuhören und
ich stelle mir die Frage in welchem Land
ist dieser Mann eigentlich Bundeskanzler
aber
ausführen und und genauso ist es jetzt
bei dem Koalitionsgipfel passiert da
schaut ein ganzes Land zu und ein ganzes
Land weiß was die akuten Fragen unserer
Zeit sind die Frau gaschkatze hat sehr
schön skizziert und dann kommt
eigentlich überhaupt nichts raus ich
will nur mal ein paar Beispiele nennen
wir haben im Moment immer noch die Frage
die die Konstellation dass die Leute auf
die Entlastung bei Heizöl warten und auf
die Entlastung bei Pellets ist nichts
passiert ich habe in meinem Wahlkreis
habe ich mittlerweile ambulante
Pflegedienste die müssen Insolvenz
anmelden weil die Pflege des Pflegegeld
nicht ange deswegen ist obwohl das
Lauterbach seit 12 Monaten immer wieder
vollmundig ankündigt und die haben
keinen Inflationsausgleich bekommen die
haben nichts bekommen um die höheren
Spritpreise abzubilden da gibt es bis
heute keine Lösung ich dachte eigentlich
dass sowas in dem Koalitionsgipfel
besprochen wird der ganze
Haushaltsstreit ist noch überhaupt nicht
beigelegt das wird wieder aufploppen wir
kriegen das über den Flurfunk mit das
Christian Lindner auf dem Geld sitzt was
heißt auf dem Geld sitzt er sagt
richtigerweise wir haben kein Geld mehr
und wir haben für diese Wohltaten
haben wir das Geld nicht und um die
Energiepreise mal in den Fokus zu nehmen
wir hatten Glück mit einem milden Winter
und jetzt läuft die Ampel durch die
Gegend und sagt wir haben die richtige
Maßnahmen eingeleitet die Geschichte war
doch anders die der Energiepreis mag war
ein fesselt und da war vor allem mal
eine Person verantwortlich das war
Robert habe ich weil wenn ich nämlich
dann im Februar März durch die Gegend
lauft und erklärt uns geht uns geht das
Gas aus und die Leute können nicht mehr
heizen und die Firmen
wir kriegen auch keine Energie mehr und
vielleicht haben wir Blackouts davon hat
er schon im März schwatoniert dann muss
ich mich nicht wundern dass ab März die
Preise nach oben gegangen sind wir haben
eine Vervierfachung der Pelletspreise
weil große Unternehmen die sich leisten
konnten gesagt oh der Habeck hat Angst
dass wir keine Pellets mehr haben da
haben die auf dem Markt eingekauft wie
verrückt ich habe jetzt letzte Woche ein
großes Unternehmen einer der größten
Arbeitgeber in meinem Wahlkreis 471
Arbeitsplätze Automobilzulieferer die
kündigen jetzt an dass sie 2025 zu
machen und sie sagen die Ampel ist ein
Glücksfall für Deutschland wenn ich das
den Leuten dort sage werde ich mit
Gegenständen bewerfen das ist sehr schön
weil ich Ihnen mitteilen kann dass als
ich gerade aus Bayern hierher kam ich
die Meldung gesehen habe dass sogar Herr
Söder inzwischen dieser Meinung ist dass
die Ampel gut für Deutschland
tatsächlich heute am Hauptbahnhof in
München
gemacht super dass Deutschland Ticket
kommt und er will dass es sogar noch
über 2025 hinausgeht also
immer ein anderes Thema gewesen
es gibt viele Themen über die wir
diskutieren können und das machen wir
auch gleich sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie